[Music]
hi everyone um
welcome to the second talk in this
morning session on the fourth day of the
optimization
asymmetry
submit
optimization on the symmetry workshop
and
so it's great to have
full viewer guest mundo
joining us from mpi leipzig from germany
right now
and he's going to tell us about
optimizing on network
tensor network varieties
thank you and
thank you for the introduction and thank
you for inviting me to speak and uh i'm
very happy to be back at the simon says
even though virtually and um
yes i would have enjoyed to be there in
person but
i could enjoy
and uh today i want to tell you
something about work that we did like
last year together with matthias
christandl daniel stefanssa and albert
berner where we studied ways to
run optimization methods on
tensor network varieties
and so i will start telling you what
tensor network is
and uh
so transformative states are tensors in
cancer product of complex vector spaces
and in this stock l big l will always be
denoted the order of the tensor the
number of the tensor factors
and the tensor microstates are tensors
that arise via some particular tensor
contractions which are encoded in the
combinatorics of the graph so if you
were in mathias stock yesterday
matthias sort of introduced these and
kind of gave a preview to to
to my talk
and
in the in the last part of his talk
and in in his settings he described the
the setting was a little more general
like he considered hyper graphs not just
graphs
and in principle everything that i say
applies to the hyper graph setting that
mathias described
but it's
like there are a lot of technicalities
that one has to be careful of that so i
just want to present it in the case of
simple graphs
and
so let me tell you that tensor networks
like appear in uh quantum mechanical
systems
in quantum physics where
in they were
studied in these uh in the context of
quantum physics under this name but they
appear in a number of different fields
so yesterday in peterborough stock
algebraic branching programs were
mentioned
and other branching programs are
a polynomial version of tensor networks
and in machine learning there are linear
networks deeply and networks in
particular that
are nothing else than a particular case
of tensor networks
where in machine learning one wants to
introduce some
[Music]
non
nonlinear
factor with with some
yeah there is like some some no
linearity is introduced but they are
essentially the tensor networks in
algebra statistics there is a
probability model there is this is a
generalization of markov models that are
called graphical models and under some
identification and understand duality
these are essentially tensor networks
and
a particular case of a graphical model
in mathematical theology is what is a
phallogenetic tree which describes
evolution of speeches and this again is
a tensor network on e3
and from a geometric point of view
these tensor networks form algebraic
varieties some distance united states
from algebraic varieties which have a
rich representation theoretical
structure and i like geometry i like
representation theory so i i
like to work with these things and uh
marginal geometry can say
a lot of things about about the sense of
dancers
so if there is any question like please
interrupt me at any time
so to tell you what uh tell you
precisely what the sensor networks are i
want to introduce the definition of a
graph answer
and a graph tensor is a tensor is
associated to a weighted graph so like
the elements are a graph like the the
graph where set of vertices
the v of gamma and the set of edges e of
gamma
and
a set of integer weights
on the edges
in this case i have a picture of a
triangle with weights and one m two and
m3
and these weights are called bond
dimensions usually
and
l
the number i will cook up a tensor on l
factors and l will be the number of
vertices
[Music]
and so to construct this answer i first
attach
an identity matrix
on
each edge oh sorry
on each edge of my graph on identities
of the size equal to the bond dimension
and
so here i i'm sort of cheating a little
bit i'm identifying a primal and dual
but i want to think of this identity
matrix as an identity that maps a vector
space on one end of my
edge to the other end
of my edge
and
so i have these
these identity matrices one on every
edge
and now i cancel them all together and
when i cancel them all together i get
this big big tensor
with with as many factors as twice the
number of edges
so i have the first identity matrix that
is in cm1 tensor cm1 and then the second
in cm2 tensor cm2 and the third one in
cm3 transfer cm3 i transfer all of them
together and i get this answer on six
factors
and
now what i do i want to group together
the factors that correspond to the same
vertex that are the same vertex
and i regarded this big product this big
identity as a tensor on l factors on as
many factors as the number of vertices
where my factors have some inner tensor
structures so which i in some way i want
to forget i want to forget that these
inner factors have the sensor structure
i just want to view it from outside as
the tensor on l factors
and
i will call
w v
like v is the is a vertex small v is a
vertex and i will call w's these big
factors
and so i get the my graph answer is is
this time so now factors which is
constructed in this way and the notation
will be p gamma for the graph and m for
the bond dimensions
[Music]
and from this tensor i want to construct
a variety
and i want to construct a variety inside
some other tensor products sometimes the
product of v1
vl
where the dimensional of the djs are njs
and to do that i look at this map
and the
i look at all possible l tuples
of linear map mapping the
the wv the the w space corresponding to
vertex v
to the
v space corresponding to vertex mode v
and i just hit my
my graph tensor with this uh multiple of
linear maps
and in this way i i let these linear
maps vary
and i get set i get a set that is the
image of this uh
for this evaluation map
and i call these
these i use this notation t and s
potential network states and with a
little circle up here this is not yet a
variety
and when i take the closure
and the disclosure is equivalent if you
take in the zariski topology or in the
euclidean topology of the complex vector
spaces i get an algebraic variety and
this algebraic variety is the tensor
network variety that i interested in
so
it is
defined as the image of a polynomial
phi
which is just evaluation of a bunch of
linear functions of the tensor product
of bunch of linear functions
on on the graph tense
okay
[Music]
okay
let's look at an example a very simple
example
so we consider the graph with just two
vertices and one sorry yes two vertices
and one edge and m will be the bond
dimension of my edge and in this case
the graph tensor is just an identity
there is only one edge so it's just
there
and it's an identity from w1 to the
that is a cm on this side to w2 which is
a cm on this other side on the on the
two side
and now
i
pick two vector spaces v1 and v2 of
dimension n1 and n2 and my evaluation
map just maps
a two linear maps which are a matrix of
size n one
times m
and a matrix of size
and 2 times m
and with this pair of matrices it hits
this identity matrix and if you write
everything coordinates you see
that this is really picking uh
multiplying on one side is identity by
x1 and on the other side by x2 but to
make dimensions work i have to take a
transpose
and so this is like this x1 x2 transpose
is
the image of my phi
as as this linear maps vary
[Music]
and in this case the the tensor network
these open part of the tensor network
variety are just matrices
in b1 tensor b2 of rank at most m
because they factor as
an n1 by m matrix times an m by n2
matrix
and in this case it turns out that in
fact this is already closed i don't need
to take a closure okay
is that any question
okay
good
yeah
okay
and let's say some easy property of
these uh graph cancers and distance or
network varieties so if i have an edge
of weight one
is the same as not having an edge in the
graph
because if i have a weight one really in
my graph cancer i just have a one by one
identity matrix that then when i hit
with the linear maps i just have a
scalar floating around
but the scalars will be there anyway
because i have them from the other
innermost
in the rest of the talk i will always
assume that my weights are at least two
[Music]
and
there is a multiplicativity
property where if i take
a two graph answers on the same graph
and i take their chronicle product the
chronicle this is the times orthogonal
product which is like the tensor version
of the matrix kronecker product where i
multiply
my tensor by taking their tensor product
and then grouping together factors
that are in the same position
this is the same as taking the graph
tensor of
weight
where i take the entry wise product of
the weights
and this is because i'm chronicling
together these identities on each
edge
but the identity of size m times the
identity chronically identity of size
and prime is just the identity of size m
times sample
there is a monotonicity that if you want
comes from this property but it's a
little more general that if
m prime if m is larger than m prime
entry wise
then the tensor network varieties are
one inside the other
[Music]
and there is a universality property
where it says if gamma is connected in
the sense
that i mentioned at the first point
where all the weights are at least two
and the graph is connected
then if the bond dimensions are large
enough
these uh the transformative variety fits
the space at some point
and in fact also if m is large enough
also the open part like they may be for
a larger for larger bond dimensions but
also the the
tensor network variety with a little
circle with the open part is
fills the space eventually
and then there is a
like some geometric property
irreducibility and invariance under
scaling that
i have my my variety is defined as the
closure of the image of a polynomial map
with an irreducible domain which is just
the product of home spaces so in
particular it will be irreducible
it is very very super variety and it's
invalid and there is scaling if there is
a tensor there is also every scalar
multiple of that tensor
and so it honestly defines a variety in
projective space
i can identify it with its
projectilization
okay this is the
some easy property that would be useful
later
and uh let's see why we care about these
varieties
and here i will be a little uh
sort of like
a little vague but the idea is that uh
it is easy to evaluate graph cancer if
you compare with the evaluation of other
tensors in the same space sugar sensors
are so structured
that it's easy to evaluate and you can
think of this evaluation in
more or less the way that you want like
tensors correspond to multi-linear maps
and you can think of these as evaluating
them with linear map
or you can if you
are from a the quantum information
community
your evaluation is uh
to consider some for example evaluating
some observable on on your tensor
and this is some sort of tensor
contraction with a big matrix and if you
do it uh for graph tensors this is easy
this is easier than other tensors in the
same space
and so what's the strategy say that i
care about the answer t in cn tensor
sentence or sienna
and
i want to find a tensor network
representation from my t so maybe i
choose a graph gamma and a small with
small bond dimensions so that i know
that evaluating the graph cancer is easy
and and then i hope to find these linear
maps maybe i know my cancer and i run
again some some numeric some
optimization process to find this tensor
to find to find is the an l tuple of
linear maps
that uh realize that they give a cancer
network representation
for my answer t so that realize might
answer t
as uh image of the graph of the answer
and then i use the fact that i know how
to evaluate the graph tensor to evaluate
and here i'm swapping a lot of stuff
under the rug
but this is more or less the idea and
this strategy uses the open part i want
to find this axis the open part of the
tensor network variety as an ansys class
for a good tensor network representation
of my cancer tea
[Music]
and
it's known that there is a class of
tensor of physical interest which is
what also mathias mentioned last night
last
morning
which are these ground states of locally
gapped militants
which are known to have good and tensor
network representation so if i know that
my cancer is a quantum state
that describes the ground state of the
local government then i know that there
will be a graph which sort of depends on
the
geometry of the system
and small bond dimensions
which
for which this representation exists
and so i want to find it
and
there is a natural question which is
what happens at the boundary
so what if my
tensor that i care about leaves in this
difference so when i try to run some
optimization method when i try to run
some numerics this will not work because
maybe this this this x1 xl don't exist
i mean if it is in the boundary they
don't exist but i can approach my hands
arbitrarily close and usually what
happens is that
the problem becomes the conditioned the
when when you run these uh the numerics
these uh
the entries of these matrices explode
and
things like that
[Music]
and so there is another question of what
what what can i do in those cases
and and of course
yes
[Music]
um i have a question about this uh
statement that
ground states of local gaps hamiltonians
have good tns representation this is a
heuristic statement or this is a theorem
and also what is the
underlying network if you know
you really assume that the system is
living anywhere on a graph like
right so if you
there are it depends on the system it
depends on the graph so for what are
called matrix product states which are
tensor network where your graph is a
path or a ring
then
they're known to have i i don't remember
the
top of my head delayed the parameters
but
then given the
the local dimension of your of your
tensor and
then then it is known that there is a a
matrix products and you know that it is
uh the ground state of uh a local gap to
miltonian on a path or on a ring
then they are known to have a good
attention like representation
and for other things like peps meta
other type of graphs
i think it's not very well understood
what
if it is precisely like
last yesterday matthias mentioned this
aria law
which plays a role in this construction
but i don't know the
[Music]
is an details
which doesn't you know
yes
approximation is not in your formulation
of
the variety you also want i mean you you
want to
yes i agree that the
in in
for diario law only gives you well i i
think it depends a little bit on
on the
on the settings but in principle yes the
aria law only gives only tells you that
you can approximate it well
[Music]
with respect to the parameters of the
system
hey thanks for you
[Music]
okay
so
[Music]
let's
uh
is it okay can
something happen no okay
so let's see what can we say about the
boundary
so
there is uh there is a theorem which i
state again like in sort of an imprecise
way but this is sort of the
the idea of the theorem and there are
like
there is some range in the in the
precise statement
which is uh
in in
some range it was proved by landsberg
nyan chiang kai in 2012 and last this
year like battle when physique uh
refined this uh
this statement
where like if uh if gamma doesn't have
cycles then the cancer network the open
part of the sensory is already closed
you don't need to take closure and if
gamma has cycles then if the boundary is
not empty unless it is empty for trigger
reasons like for instance
maybe the one dimension is so large that
this already fills the space and then of
course the boundary is empty
and other
things like that can happen but i don't
want to get into technicalities
uh
further in the work of 2020 the
christian de lucia verona and werner
proved
that sometimes
in some setting
these
tensor networks that are ground states
of uh
locally
that hamiltonians lie on the boundary in
the sense that yes you can find a good
and solid representation
but even if we with
even smaller bond dimensions you can
prove that they are in the boundary
also for some smaller bond dimension
and so
what we try to do is
that we determine the nuances class with
two properties so these uh evaluation
properties that are easy for the tensor
network access class are still easy in
the nuances class
and
and this class includes stays at the
boundary
so we can reach a little bit of the
boundary
and to do this we use the geometry of
the oscillating spaces of this variety
and in the rest of the talk i will try
to tell you a little bit more about this
there's another question for you yes
hold on
[Music]
uh hi uh
all this stuff does it like this is the
answers is it like related to better
answers because in beta is also you
start with like
a system without like on trees no cycles
and you approximate the general
so again so the resistance
physics phenomena that
if you have no if it's no no cycles you
can compute partition function
efficiently
and in general you need to do this
better answers which is good so anyway
is did somebody study is it like some
kind of a quantum generalization of
of better answers i
don't know
thanks i know for like
if you consider
like
for instance for i don't know if this is
related by for tensor network
representation for instance on binary
trees
are related with the with this
hierarchical attacker decomposition of
your tensor
i don't know if this is related in any
way
but i i don't know
[Music]
can i make a comment and i'll ask you a
question for you yes um
so i think people i mean
i don't know the full answer but i think
people have studied they've used the
beta answers to construct for example
matrix product state so these one
dimensions translate network
descriptions some special cases but i
don't know if there's a general
correspondence or inclusion i guess
the question i want to ask is um
maybe you mentioned this but if you
make the bond dimension larger
do then things that previously were in
the boundaries somehow become now part
of the interior or something like that
yes and i will and yes and i will say
something about that in a second
yeah i would say something more precise
about that in a second yes of course you
you can always make the one-dimensional
larger and but that's kind of an
expensive way to
to get stuff at the boundary
but i will say because you're okay um
and can i ask about the evaluation being
easy i mean in general have like a
general graph that's not easy to
compute with tensor networks well yes
that's true it's not easy but it's it's
yeah
again it was sort of big but it's still
easier than it enter in the same space
and then if you begin general tensor
i guess to if i have even if i have an
abs representation it's better than
having no representation at all
and of course like if you have a matrix
positive state representation is
particularly easy if you have like three
representations it's easier and easier
than for you kind of means sort of as
easy as sort of an ordinary tensor
network on the same graph or kind of the
same order of magnitude yes
yes
okay thank you
okay
uh
to
let me introduce this uh this definition
of restriction degeneration which is
also what matthias mentioned last
yesterday
and we say that the tensor s in a
process of w vector spaces and uh
restricts to a tensor t in a product of
v vector spaces
where
if there are linear maps such that i can
realize t as the image of s
and i say that it is a degeneration if i
can do this uh
after possibly passing 20 meters so if i
if my tensor i say the test that
generates to t if t is limit is a limit
of restrictions of s
in this sense
and
with this terminology this
open part of the tensor network variety
is the set of full restrictions of
microsensor and
the actual tensioner variety is the set
of all the generations
and
so at
mitchell was mentioning like there is a
an easy way to
pick to pick up uh tensors at the
boundary which is just let's make the
one dimension bigger and eventually we
will eventually like we will fill the
space so in particular at some point we
will get just the boundary
let's see how we can do this
well there is a
a an easy way which
i mean we we didn't find it in the
literature but it's sort of so easy that
had been known for sure and
if say that
p lives in the tensor network with one
dimension m and now for simplicity i'm
always taking like local dimensions to
be all the same equals to small n and
the bond dimensions to be all the same
equals to small n
and let's say that my t i can express it
as a
the generation of the the graph tensor
of both dimension m
[Music]
then
it is a restriction of the graph tensor
with one dimension big m for some m
which is bounded above by a power of uh
the small n
where this power only depends on the
combinatorics of gamma and particularly
does not depend on the bone dimensions
and it does not depend on the local
dimensions
and
and i give you a very
fast idea of the proof
so there is
a path if i have a path
um like the tensor network uh on on a
path then
the graph cancer on the path restricts
to the edge joining
the extremes of the path and these in
quantum information is called quantum
teleportation
or in geometry is like
usually just a flattening argument
and
this means that the tensor network on
the path
restricts to the tensor network which
only has one edge on joining the two the
two extremes of the path with the same
bond dimension but then i can use my
multiplicativity property
i can pick two copies of these and
tensor net together transfer them
together i restrict one to the opposite
edge
and i realized the graph tensor on the
triangle as a restriction of the graph
tensor on the path with square bond
dimension
[Music]
and
but this tells me that every
degeneration of the graph tensor on the
triangle with one dimension m is a
degeneration of the
graph tensor on the path with square the
bond dimension
but the path doesn't have cycles and so
the oh it's the generations and
restrictions and since all these
generations are restrictions i realize
my
all the degenerations of the triangle as
restrictions of this of this path
and in general the argument is a little
more complicated when you have to
replace the path with spanning trees
with a spanning tree of your graph and
if you are a little then you can use
this argument to sort of like cover the
missing edges from the spanning tree
and that's why you in principle you need
more than two
then more than the square
and
can i just ask for like a square grid of
say n by n square k by k squared like
like yes then this is okay
yes this is very big this becomes very
good okay so it's horrible we have the
we have the number in the thing but it's
some yes
it's something like i think at least
quadratic in the size of the kilo of
degrees
well no okay maybe
but this is like not constant basically
like it really grows no no no no
it gets bigger yeah
and uh so this argument is completely
topological it doesn't tell you anything
it doesn't tell you how to do it at all
so let's try to do a little better
and to do a little better i want to tell
you something about how the generations
look like
well i if s degeneracy to t then i can
find these linear maps that give me a
path to well give me like a curve
on the that of restrictions of s
that converges to t and i can do this
with
choosing linear mass which is defined
polynomial in epsilon putting only in my
in a parameter on the curve
and i can i can express this in this way
so that the
my restrictions look like epsilon to the
a for some
constant a
times t 0 plus higher order terms which
depend polynomially in epsilon
and
when i pass to the limit i divide by a
power of a
the power of epsilon this way and i get
t in the limit so this t 0 this leading
term of my
of my curve is the tensor t that i care
about
and uh
we call this a the thing that i divide
by the approximation degree and e the
error degree
e is the
number of terms that i end up with up
here
and uh
and these numbers tell us how far the
degeneration is from being a restriction
how how
hot
like how much is really a limit rather
than arrest friction and from a
geometric point of view e is the degree
of the approximating curve in projectile
space
because like if you introduce a space so
you divide by epsilon is absolutely a
washes out and you are left with a curve
of degree e
and a is a little bit more complicated
and we'll tell you two at the end how
what is it's wrong
and now we can
use
this e
to get
a better bound
than the one before or at least like a
more
explicit one
so let's say that t
is and this was like first idea on
tensors of whether three is due to being
in strassen from the 60s and the 70s and
then in this work by matthias angelo and
peter and albert they proved that they
wrote it down explicitly for graft
answers and for pencil networks
so let's say that t is a degeneration
with the bond dimension m so it leaves
in the tensor network variety we want to
mention m possibly at the boundary
but i know that my degeneration has
has error degree e
then i can show that t is a restriction
of the graph cancer with one dimension
big m where this m is bounded above by e
plus one times smaller
and
well i give you an idea of the proof
as we said before
e is the degree of the approximating
curve
and the points on the curve at least
generic points on the curve
are restrictions around its restrictions
and there is a classical fact in
geometry that the e plus one generic
points on a curve of degree e have the
same span as the whole curve
so in particular e plus one points on
the approximating curves on the limit
point
and what i can do i can pick e
plus one points and if i can
simultaneously do these e plus one
restrictions
then i can interpolate to the
restrictions and get my my point in the
limit and this is how the argument works
[Music]
and so there is a problem of course here
that
this e is something that is very hard to
control it's not
nobody knows how big it can be or
like also it
most certainly depends like as the
number of vertices grows this
like the possible ease will grow like
the highest possible it will grow
and uh
so again this is
it but we get about
[Music]
and now we
would like to do something which doesn't
just increase the bond dimension but
does something slightly different now
and to do that we want to use this
approximation degree
and i recall from before that
my
degeneration my approximating curve
looks like
epsilon to the a times t
plus a higher order terms higher order
in epsilon
and
these axes these linear maps depend
polynomially in epsilon so i can write
them in this way x j of epsilon will be
a sum of uh
some some curve of in the space of
linear maps which depends polynomial in
absolute
and
well what is this tensor product here
i'm just expanding this tensor part of
all these summations and i expanded in
powers of epsilon
and this is how how
this sort of like
multinomial formula for tensor so i
don't know how to call it but this is
this is what you get when you expand
everything
and you get the sum over like to get the
term of degree p in epsilon you get the
sum over all the possible pieces that
adapt to p
[Music]
and
well if these
in the end is epsilon to the a times t
what should happen is that if p is less
than a
then when i hit
my my tensor s with this big linear map
then i get i have to get zero because
that doesn't appear
in uh in my curve
and when i hit it
with the piece of degree a i will get t
so the point is that what if i was able
to just hit us with this piece this is
the prime dependency this is not a
product uh
a tensor part of linear maps so i'm not
allowed in principle to just hit it with
this and in fact my team will not be a
restriction
but what if i can design a a
way to
just hit my ass with this dance we did
sorry with this
big linear map
and that's what we did
we defined this state that we call the
weight state
and
this is a answer in
the product
of
spaces of dimension a plus one
which is sort of a monomial version of
uh
of a kind of a
a
tensorial version of a monom
and it's just like if i say that the v
zero has weight zero v one has weight 1
and so on
this is like the sum of all the
basis tensor of all the tensor products
of weight a
and i just i just picked this big sum
and if you want these are generalization
of tangent vectors so to the variety of
rank one tensors that are related with
higher fundamental forms of the
varieties of random tensors
when a is equal to one these are really
tangent vectors
and
there is an easy observation that i just
mentioned very fast
is that if s degenerates to t with
approximation degree a
then t is a restriction of s and here i
should have written a chronicle product
with this weight state
and this weight state is symmetric so it
doesn't really matter
what factors i give to what factors of s
and using these we define our nuances
class
and
which are all the restrictions
of
my the graft answer answered with this
weight state
and this contains his unsuspect contains
all the degeneration of the graft answer
with approximation degree at most a
and
yes this is our
this was like our idea to to do this
and
so the new class is this it contains
sensor at the boundary and we prove good
evaluation properties in the sense that
i
roughly mentioned before in the sense
that
we we can control the overhead
like how much more expensive it is to
evaluate to evaluate this
discounted product compared to
evaluating the the original graph cancer
and to do this when we use two
properties that i
just mentioned of these uh of this
weight state so they have minimal border
rank if you know what the rank is
and uh
they
have a small tensor network
representation
for these like we can write down the
small testosterone relations so if you
want to using the tension network
presentation you can go back to it one
of the previous statements where you
just enlarge the bond dimension you
enlarge one dimension so that your
auxiliary piece of the tensor network
produces this uh this weight state and
you get uh
you did this method kind of fits in
there in the ones that were there before
so just to recap
so there are these standard
representations that are useful to do
evaluation of tensors
and sometimes it's useful to have a good
way to evaluate tensors at the boundary
and and there are several ways to do
that
to find good tensor network
presentations for the boundary tensors
we can enlarge the bond dimension
or we try to define a nuances class and
i want to say we kind of run
like none of us is like a numerical
analyst so we
sort of picked the existing code and
existing methods the four tensor
networks and we modified in a way to
include these weight states
and we try to run it and they and they
run better they i mean it's better than
just enlarging the one dimension
and but we didn't do any kind of precise
analysis in in that direction but in we
can control the overhead in in the
complexity of doing these calculations
and of course there is uh
like next what can we do next well this
new class doesn't just contain
the original class or tensors at the
boundary it's honestly bigger it
contains more stuff
so there is another question on how much
bigger it is
and
what are the newt answers good for can
we can we use them to
to to describe
some to give representations of some
other tensor that is useful
and with this i think guys
is what i wanted to say
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so we have plenty of time for questions
terry
from the chat
hello everyone
[Music]
so
does it help you in any way get any
better algorithms for make this
multiplication these new answers to us
not really
no
we
have
an example
no i mean the simple question is no
because it they kind of go in the other
direction also like the the matrix
multiplication tensor is the graph
answer associated to the triangle the
one that i showed at the beginning
and and what we're doing here we're
doing the generations of that matrix
multiplication tense
so it's sort of in the other direction
we don't we don't
find a good representation the dimension
multiplication tensor is a graph tensor
yeah of course but you can have direct
sum of uh some rectangular matrix
multiplication tensor there are also
tensor networks reduce them degenerate
them to other
other thumbs so yeah we can think yeah
okay we didn't think too much about that
but it might be something
interesting to look at no we i i don't
know all right
here's another one second
[Music]
so in uh in quantum mechanics one i
think one important operation you can do
on
on these tensors is to contract them
take two two tenses and contract
partially contract
is there is that an operation which can
be represented in terms of the
underlying graph is that something which
means doing something to the underlying
graph
yes so of course it depends
which spaces you want to contract with
which spaces
but in principle what what you do is
that you get like two graphs
and then you sort of glue together some
of the vertices
and uh
and this the contraction will be
the contraction of the two
of the two graph dancers
in in some particular way that you want
to do
and and yes and this is like you can do
it if we tensor networks with with uh
sorry let me say in some cases like of
course there is like
it depends on the graph but uh in uh if
your graph for some particular graph
this can be done very efficiently with
graph time so for instance for matrix
valid state so this is very easy
and for trees that is also easy and sort
of like as i mentioned earlier there is
this when your attention network is a
tree then this is really with this uh
hierarchical attack target decomposition
and when you have a a representation of
your tensor doing contraction is easier
and
you can do it
more efficiently thanks
[Music]
questions
[Music]
fulvio i had one question sort of a
basic one
for these tensor network varieties
you know it'd be interesting to know
their equations right
yes it would be very interesting to know
their equations and i'm sure it's
complicated of course
but how about you know sort of easy
cases like what i'm thinking is
if you have a graphical model
on discrete random variables
you know exactly when the
the
the model is defined by quadratic
polynomials yes so is there anything
like that for this uh
so let me i i'm not sure if there are
good settings where you can say that
equations are quadratic i would be
surprised if you if there are
unless unless of course like dimensions
are very small or
like if the one dimension is very small
for instance if the one dimensions are
one then you get rank one tensors and
they are defined by quadratic right
right but already if you they get a
little bigger or you would expect that
the quadratic kind of disappear i guess
what i'm telling you is
is like a graphs like in again graphical
models case
if the graph happens to be
decomposable right if it's a
triangle free no not triangle free but
chordal call the graphs
then
that's saying that the equations have to
be quadratic oh yes that's true is
anything
like that
i'm not sure but let me say like if if
you don't have cycles
then you can write everything in terms
of rank conditions okay okay because you
have these flattening so when you
separate you you split your graph like
every whenever you touch an edge you
make a cut of the graph
that cut has some defined selenium map
and elena method has bounded rank
bounded by the the the size of the cut
yeah
and uh and this is this gives some
equations and this can you do it in
general like we have to work with
michelle and jane lansberg where we
study these cuts for for metrics for the
states
so my next question is
sorry
let me add something that we have uh
cases where we have all the equations
well some very small case
the
there is another work with alexander
bernardi and claudia delazari where we
look at two very small cases among other
things
one is the graph cancer on the triangle
with one dimension two and
size
and local dimensions 3
and in this case
if i'm not wrong you get equations of
degree 8 all equations of degree 8
and then there is another case which is
like on the square with one dimension
two and local dimensions two your tensor
network is a hypersurface of degree six
okay okay and this great
degree six is of course everything is
important and the reaction of the
general linear group acting on the
vertices
and so it is an invariant for this
equation is an environment for this
action and it has very very nice
expression it's easy to
to check if something is zero non-zero
okay
or degree things yeah my last question
is so at the very early stage of your
talk you mentioned its properties
and there was this multiplicative
property there so you had the same graph
i think
yeah
exactly the same graph but the m's
changed you know and then you took the
kronecker product
um so when i saw that i thought about
sort of the multiplicative property of
the maximum likelihood degree
yeah so you know if
yeah yeah so so i mean i can read this
equation from right to left so you have
a tensor network and you're decomposing
it it's kind of into two
tensor networks if that happens again
for instance for graphical models in a
nice way
then you can look at the maximum
lactodegra
of the bigger model
and that that's equal to the product of
the maximum like the degrees of the of
the
smaller ones
is pretty much the same
if i am not uh
okay
yeah i think i think the reason is more
or less the same okay
it's the same multiplicativity like the
the one writes down everything i think
that you get multiplicativity in the in
the graphical setting because of this
multiplicativity or the other way around
okay good all right thank you
anything else any other questions
[Music]
okay uh thanks fulvio uh thank you very
much thanks doc and uh
so we yeah
one more time
um
thank you and uh yeah so there is so
we're finishing off here and then there
is a another talk at two o'clock this
afternoon
okay thank you again
[Music]